late last night the house committee
investigating the deadly siege at the
capitol on january 6 last year issued a
subpoena to the secret service the
panels requesting the agency turn over
texts and other information after the
secret service was accused of deleting
text messages sought as evidence scott
mcfarland is in our washington bureau
with the latest scott good morning
adriana good morning to you the
committee's next public hearing is set
for thursday in prime time but in the
overnight hours the investigation has
already ascended to a new level
in a subpoena issued overnight the
january 6 committee is seeking
potentially pivotal text messages
between secret service agents on january
5th and january 6 the day of the attack
messages an internal watchdog says
disappear the communications could be
key to advancing testimony from former
white house aide cassidy hutchinson who
suggested donald trump demanded agents
take him to the capitol and that he got
into a physical altercation with his
senior agent the president said
something to the effect of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now the
committee said it'll seek a way to
recover and retrieve the missing
messages virginia democrat elaine lauria
sits on the panel are you concerned
about those secret service messages very
concerned about the secret service
messages the communications within the
secret service he was protecting the
president and the vice president at the
critical time on january 6 when the
violence broke out that's of utmost
interest to the committee an internal
homeland security department watchdog
said the secret service erased its own
text messages after the texts were
requested to be handed over as part of
an internal review of the capital riot
the chairman of the january 6 committee
said the secret service hasn't been
fully cooperating with that internal
review the agency disputed the charges
but said some data was lost during a
previously planned system migration for
the secret service to have so casually
allowed important evidence to be erased
really just looks very odd and this is
what gives rise to questions about
what actually happened and why the
secret service did what it did
meanwhile two former trump aides who
defied this committee are now set for
criminal contempt of congress trials
former trade adviser peter navarro we
learned yesterday rejected a plea deal
he'll go on trial in november and former
trump aide steve bannon set for trial
monday morning here in washington
dana narrow
scott you mentioned that that next
hearing will be thursday in prime time
what do we know about it
according to committee members speaking
with cbs news they're going to focus on
what they characterize as dereliction of
duty by former president trump they're
going to focus on the afternoon itself
of january 6th what donald trump did
what he didn't do what he said what he
didn't say as the riot was taking place
they've already accused donald trump of
being part of a conspiracy to defraud
the united states but they're going to
drill down on the afternoon of the sixth
itself
and the allegation scott is that the
former president inspired all of those
who stormed the capital that day where
do the prosecution stand for all of
those who have been arrested as of this
morning about 850 federal defendants so
far about a third of them a little more
than a third have pleaded guilty but
look at the bottom number about 50 are
charged with conspiracy accused of
plotting and planning and being ready
for an attack on january 6. here's the
question that will define the rest of
this year and likely next year in this
investigation
how many other people are charged
because of what the january 6 committee
found for being part of what the
committee considers a conspiracy
who in this investigation will the
justice department pick up on and file
charges against
good point these probes are not over yet
scott mcfarlane thank you for joining us